you
you
the old ones perished a thousand years
ago
they're great cities
turned to graves
in their place
came new life
[Music]
dangers
[Music]
I must find a way to stop it
get worse
[Music]
until it destroys us all
there's nothing I wouldn't do to save
this world
no depths I won't explore
[Music]
no secret I won't unlock
no barrier I won't cross
[Music]
this mission is my
if I falter if I fail
there won't be anyone left to stop
coming
[Music]
[Music]
but whatever comes
we'll be ready
you
on behalf of the entire team at gorilla
we're happy to share the first look at
horizon forbidden West we're continuing
a love story as she moves West to a far
future America to brave a beautiful but
dangerous frontier mess with mysterious
new frets get ready to explore distant
lands ravaged by massive storms and take
on new powerful machines as you return
to majestic world of Verizon stay tuned
for much more we can't wait for you to
get your hands on it I think there's a
lot to look forward to for the community
they fans are gonna be really pleased as
a game designer and storyteller this is
incredibly exciting we're talking a
whole new generation of ideas and
experiences that we can create for the
player no matter where they are no
matter who they are new experiences like
we've never had before
more iconic interesting characters more
atmospheric immersive worlds for plants
to explore we want to WoW players
respect the unexpected and I for one
can't wait can't wait we can't wait to
share them with you is so exciting
incredibly exciting it's really about